what is data right I'm pretty sure
that's data right is this data you know
picture or that data is this data what
what is data so we talked a lot about
data in the last video why is it
important that we can analyze and
understand data but what is data
everybody has data everybody's
generating it companies is generating on
us we're generating it ourselves you
know when we use social media so on but
what is it and understanding what it is
is a prerequisite for being able to use
it properly perhaps the most important
thing as far as we're concerned so
people who are trying to analyze data
sort of scientifically is the data has
to be measurable right so the idea is
you know if you're going to do a survey
on what people like everyone's got to be
using the same scale and the same rating
system otherwise it doesn't make any
sense well we can't have someone rating
things from one to five and someone else
saying I thought it was good right
because which one of one to five is good
we don't you know we don't know all
right so if I was going to be doing the
same thing your data's got to be a
consistent format and once that's
achieved at least we're a little bit
closer to be able to make some sense of
it broadly speaking when we talk about
data we kind of have four different
types and we summarize this with this
nice noir word so n oh I R ma and each
of these different types of data we can
do different things with all right so n
that's the first type so this is nominal
data the normal data is where we have no
distance between the values that we can
measure right because they're not really
quantities and we can't order them so a
good example would be colors so maybe
you have your favorite color is red and
my favorite color is blue I don't know
which is better than the other there is
no measurement between them right is
blue closer to green the medes you know
that doesn't make any sense right we're
not talking about wavelengths we're just
talking about the colors right another
good example would be lets say in
football player numbers on your back
right now
symbolically sometimes certain player
numbers have a meaning but you got you
can't compare and contrast them you
can't say that 8 is 2 times better than
4 all right that doesn't make any sense
right you also can't really order them
in general right player 16 doesn't go
before or after player 13 in a list but
you know but that doesn't make any sense
right so normal data is data where and
it's useful right it could be really
important but it's data where we we kind
of have labels but no way of ordering
these labels so you can still analyze it
but you can't for example calculator
the average that the mean average right
that wouldn't make any sense what you
can do is calculate the mode so you can
calculate the most common one so you
could say that more people prefer red to
blue but you couldn't say you know the
average color that people like is a sort
of muddy brown right handsome doesn't
make any sense at all right so as we go
down this list we get slightly more and
more informative in some sense types of
data so the next one is ordinal so in
ordinal data we have an order but we
can't measure distances between things
so a good example would be something
like positions people finished in a race
so you know maybe I finished first I'm
super quick right you didn't you
finished third but how far we are a part
that isn't included in that kind of data
you'd have to have a separate value for
that another example what we're all
familiar with is rating systems right so
perhaps you I rate a film from one to
five stars and you rate the film from
one to five stars but you can't really
save a film that's called four stars is
two times better than one that scored
two because that's a very subjective and
it's there's no real sort of measurable
distance between these stars if you have
ordinal data you can calculate the mode
again you can calculate the most common
value of all the values that were
returned or you can calculate the median
the one that sits in the middle right so
maybe you know fifty runners in a race
the 25th position roughly speaking is
going to be you know around the median
so it's still not hugely useful right
the next up we have interval data
interval data we have an order and we
have a distance but we have no sort of
absolute zero for this scale so a good
example would be something like degree
Celsius I or degrees Fahrenheit zero
degrees Celsius isn't no temperature
it's it's a specific temperature right
so we can't say that fifty degrees is
half of a hundred degrees I have a
numbers a half but doesn't really make
sense right they are we can we can say
that a hundred degrees is hotter than 50
which is hotter than zero right so this
is interval data now interval data lets
us do a few more things than we could
with ordinal as well as be able to
calculate the mode and median we can now
calculate the mean temperature that's
okay and we could also calculate things
like the rain the minimum and maximum
temperatures for a certain window right
so that's pretty useful another good
example of interval will be pH level
right again the pH of zero means very
acidic it doesn't mean there is no
acidity at all or no pH at all we can
say that a
so 13 is higher than a pH of 7 is higher
than a pH of 3 and we know how far apart
these numbers are but we can't
necessarily say if one is double one
another one so the final kind of data
we're going to look at is ratio data so
this is exactly like interval except we
now have a sort of true zero value so a
good example of this would be degrees
Kelvin why so Kelvin has an absolute
zero which is the absolute average
absence of any kind of heat right and
when it goes upwards so we can say that
in terms of Kelvin a hundred is half of
200 and so on like this and we can get
to 0 another example would be number of
children right zero children means the
absence of any children and you can also
say that let's say four children is
double the amount of two children and
two men to look after in my opinion so
that is an example of ratio data right
now ratio data is quite similar in terms
of what you can calculate to interval
but it allows some more complicated
statistical measures such as t-test
so these are the types of data now
actually it's quite important how you
structure your data in general we can't
just have it sitting in some massive
spreadsheet with no thought given to
where everything is right there's
actually a pretty standard way of doing
this that we're going to look at data
comes in lots of forms right different
types of measurements different
experiments people are going to collect
it in different ways but actually
there's a very standard way that we use
to represent data once it's actually on
a computer so we can add some kind of
table of our data we almost always
represent our data in a matrix like this
a two-dimensional table because it's
much easier to do and so along the top
we're going to have our attributes right
which are the the things we've been
measuring so an example would be maybe
we're collecting data on people so we
could have name that would be some
nominal data and then you know age
height so the columns are attributes all
the things we've been measuring the rows
those are the instances or the samples
we've got so that's all the individual
people so here's person 1 and person 2
person three and person 3 is called John
and there you know 54 and you know 5
foot 11 or whatever you know whatever
right and so on and you can put you know
have as many rows as you want so when we
talk about attributes we're talking
about the number of columns people use
lots of different terms for these my I
like to think of them as features
actually buttes is another one and we
have instances or samples down the rows
now quite often on the very last column
of your data sometimes they're created
out but not really important we'll have
our output maybe we're trying to make a
decision based on these people maybe
these are candidates for a football team
and we're saying you know are they gonna
be on the team or not so this is yes
no John's made it yes no no and so on
and that way we could perhaps analyze
our decision-making process and decide
you know is there any aspect of these
things that inform our decision-making
process as an example right now we
always structure data in this way but if
we don't it becomes a huge problem
because you end up spending all this
time formatting and trying to work out
what's what and you know why is John
listed down the table or not across the
table and you know nothing makes any
sense anymore
so let's look at an actual data set and
we'll see all this in action so we have
here a data set of whether someone goes
to play tennis right and whether or not
they go is going to depend a little bit
on what the weather conditions are right
so we don't like to play for example
when it's too hot the tennis data set is
just the same structure as a data set we
looked at already we're gonna load it in
an r it's held in a CSV file so tennis
read CSV tennis now we're using R for
this because it's free and it has a load
of decent functions for analyzing
examining visualizing data right so
we're going to be using it throughout
these videos obviously you could use
MATLAB or Python or some other library
if you wanted to I think that you should
use whatever you're most comfortable
with
you could do this data analysis in Excel
some people would disagree
now Excel is perfectly good for what it
does you could do with data analysis in
it I think that excel in it doesn't
enforce anything to do with observations
versus variables and things like that
these are distinctions that are not
really made in Excel obviously if you
enforce those rules yourself that's
going to work but you have to be a
little bit more you know regimented in
war based about it I think the consensus
would be that if you really want to get
into data analysis and start doing
things like principal component analysis
or more advanced statistical measures
something like R or Python is going to
help a lot more okay so i've load of a
data set and if we look up a data set so
we look at the top few rows of a data
you'll see that there are 6 different
variables or six attributes and this
data set has 14 in
observations are call some observations
so what we're saying is we have six
columns and fourteen rows right of our
data set and this data set is structured
exactly like this people data set that I
was looking at a minute ago so we can
examine a single instance we can say
what is it about day three so let's have
a look at day three so we can say tennis
on day three and we can save on day
three it was overcast the temperature
was only five degrees the humidity was
high there wasn't any wind so they
decided to play tennis right so it's a
bit chilly but I guess they gave it a go
so on we could also look at all the
different temperatures for example all
the different forecasts tennis dollar
outlook
all right and we can look at all the
outlooks in the data set so we can say
we've got sunny sunny overcast rainy
rainy rainy and so on and we can get a
feel for what kind of weather we're
looking at here as well using something
like our you can examine the instances
you can examine the individual
attributes you can group them together
or not as you see fit and then you can
start to drill into what this dataset
means now this dataset has in it the
final column which is whether they
actually played so you could use
something like machine learning to
predict that final column based on the
other columns that's something you could
do one other thing about this dataset
it's quite interesting is it has a few
examples of the different kinds of data
we were looking at earlier so remember
we have nominal ordinal interval and
ratio so for example Outlook is really a
nominal field my it's a nominal data
type you could perhaps suggest that you
could order it from rainy food to sunny
but then cloudy overcast you know it
doesn't really make any sense so this is
kind of nominal you could calculate for
example the mode and say that most of
the days were rainy or something like
this temperature as we discussed before
this is in Celsius so this is going to
be interval we can order the data and we
can say but one of them is 50 away from
another one but we can't say how much of
a difference that it's like is that
double the temperature or half a
temperature we can't really say so
humidity is ordinal so we can say high
is more humidity than normal right but
we can't really say how much that's
going to depend on who was measuring it
and where their differences lie and
finally wind in kilometers per hour well
zero is no wind yeah you can't have
negative wind so this is a ratio right
you can say about 20 mile an hour wind
or 20 kilometers now
and is two times more than ten that's
something you can say this little
dataset contains all the kinds of data
so with different statistics and
measures you can calculate using these
it's going to depend on what kind of
data they are so we can see that even a
very simple data set like this has loads
of different kinds of data and different
ways we could interpret this data right
if you make a decision to play based
only on whether the outlook is good
you're maybe not going to solve the
whole problem right so these are the
kind of things we'll be looking at as we
go forward and one thing we might do
next is to visualize this data starts to
try and understand some patterns or
extract some kind of knowledge they're
very important tool but you've gotta use
it properly you can't just plot anything
and everything every chart you use has
got to support your hypothesis or it's
got to try and show the story you're
trying to tell right you don't just plot
something because it could be plotted
right it's good there's got to be a
point to if there's a lot of problems
with using inappropriate graphs and only
picking subsets of your data that's a
huge problem